salut c'est le seul vrai aujourd'hui on
va parler sécurité internet parce que
c'est vrai qu'on parle beaucoup de
technologies de smartphones de produits
on parle assez peu de logiciels et on
parle surtout assez peu de sécurité donc
l'idée aujourd'hui ça va être de vous
parler de sécurité c'est une vidéo qui
en partenariat avec hig j'ai fait
justement vous parlez du dpn de
l'intérêt d'utiliser un vpn est ce que
c'est intéressant oui ou non à quoi ça
sert à bpn
je sais pas vous moi j'en ai beaucoup
entendu parler avant de vraiment m'y
intéresser et au final se sont rendu
compte qu'avoir un vpn ça pouvait
vraiment avoir un sens ça pouvait
vraiment intéressant et ça vous en parle
tout de suite
vpn ça veut dire virtual private network
en français réseau privé virtuel
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
lorsque vous surfez sur internet vous
laissait forcément des infos ci et là
que peuvent être collectées surtout
lorsque vous sortez sur un réseau public
lorsque vous êtes par exemple dans un
restaurant ou utiliser le wifi d'une
municipalité ou quelque chose comme ça
en wifi ouverts des personnes mal
intentionnées des hackers peuvent
intercepter assez facilement toutes vos
données c'est-à-dire vos emails vos
données de carte bancaire vos mots de
passe et que sais-je encore
et d'une manière générale même lorsque
vous surfez chez vous dans un hôtel sur
des connexions sécurisées
vous donnez peuvent toujours être
interceptée par votre fournisseur
d'accès par des hackers par le
gouvernement en fait on a parlé de
paranoïa mais c'est avec vos données
personnelles peuvent être assez
facilement bombay lors qu'on s'y connaît
quand même assez pas donner à monsieur
madame tout le monde
mais vous donner peut être assez
facilement récupérer point de dire quel
est l'intérêt quelques regards de vos
emails c'est une conversation privée
c'est pas forcément une question
business pas forcément être compliquée
ou embêtant mais dites vous bien au
niveau du raisonnement est ce que vous
auriez envie que quelqu'un est axé votre
journal intime et accès à vos courriers
même s'il peut rien en faire toujours
embêtant l'idée justement au contraire
c'est protéger ses données de les
crypter de les rendre inaccessibles par
le biais d'un vpn
l'idée du vpn c'est vraiment de
sécuriser vos données pas pour vous
puissiez faire des choses délictueuse
que vous alliez pirates et que vous
allez regarder du contenu qui est
complètement illicite à dernier comme ça
c'est pas du tout ça l'idée l'idée au
contraire c'est de vous protéger
protéger vos données personnelles et
protéger plus globalement votre vie sur
internet avec un gps vous allez gagner
l'un des 10 pas en ayant une autre
adresse ip que celle de votre
fournisseur d'accès gagner en sécurité
en cryptant ont redonné ses avocats mes
contourner la censure certains pays du
monde et pouvoir naviguer sur des sites
qui sont interdits et vous allez aussi
gagné en liberté parce que vous aurez
accès à des sites qui sont bloqués avec
votre adresse ip pour notamment netflix
et que tout le contenu américain qui est
distribuée uniquement pour les us vous
n'avez pas accès parce que vous avez une
adresse ip française grâce à des
solutions vpn comics vpn vous pourrez
avoir accès à ce contenu
sans aucune restriction et ça c'est
plutôt cool idem canal+ tf1 ou même
pendant les grands matchs comme la coupe
du monde de football il ya des
problématiques de droits de
retransmission d'un pays à l'autre
si par exemple dette en france ou vers
des masses ou diffusée uniquement sur
des chaînes cryptées payante vous pouvez
par exemple l'échoppé sur des chaînes
belges
si elle ne bloque pas sauf qu'avec votre
adresse ip ça ne fonctionne pas hélas
pour coup avec une solution comics vpn
vous pouvez dans aucun problème en gros
comme ça dans des peines toutes les
données qui vont pâtir et à gré de votre
ordinateur puisque un site distant dans
une espèce de tunnel où tout est en
crypté et on n'a pas accès à l'extérieur
donc pour le goût vous êtes vraiment
tranquille
il existe différents types de vpn tout
par exemple de l'icv pen il ya un
service gratuit et un service payant
avec un service gratuit vous est la
barre de la sécurité et l'anonymat a
minima un minable pas parce que le
service n'est pas correct mais juste
parce que en termes de bande passante en
termes de serveurs ça va être moins
performant vous risquez d'avoir de la
latence ça peut aussi être un petit peu
embêtant par contre il existe des
solutions payantes à une solution
payante vous allez voir différents
serveurs qui vont être placés dans le
monde entier dans plus de 25 pays
anouk une collection ultra rapide ça
forcément ça va changer un peu la vie
parce que si vous gagnez en sécurité et
de côté sa ram ça va rapidement vous
saouler et vous allez rapidement arrêté
comme je le disais que vous avez aussi
des serveurs dédiés pour le streaming
comme netflix comme amazon prime 100 g
au bloc permet d'avoir accès à du
contenu vous n'auriez pas autrement avec
l'adresse ip de votre pays vous pouvez
choisir votre technologie avec plus de
sept tunnels de sécurité différents et
puisque cette année sans que cette
solution c'est que vous avez accès à un
service client 7 jours sur 7 24 heures
sur 24 donc si vous avez un problème
sont toujours quelqu'un pour répondre à
votre question une solution comme igpn
fonctionne aussi bien sur un smartphone
sur une tablette que sur un pc à ios
android windows mac chrome et linux
c'est vraiment hyper important de se
protéger il existe plein de solutions
l'idée c'est de trouver celle qui vous
correspond le mieux qui vous va le mieux
mais l'idée à mon avis l'idée première
de ce genre de choses c'est vraiment de
savoir dire conscience qu'il ya des
risques sur internet je dis pas ça pour
rendre les gens parano et puis pour vous
dire attention tout le monde est là tout
le monde vous surveille vous n'aurez
peut-être probablement jamais problème
peut-être que vos données bancaires ne
seront jamais récupéré mais imaginez que
vous sortez sur un wifi public que vous
êtes en train d'acheter un billet de
train quoi que ce soit que vous avez un
pirate à proximité qui a justement en
train d'essayer de récupérer les infos
vous êtes susceptibles d'être piratés ou
du moins de vous donner soit rct dont il
faut avoir conscience de ça il faut
savoir ça existe après vous pouvez aller
sur une solution comme le vpn oui ou non
c'est important de faire ses choix en
connaissance de cause
comme je le dis il existe une solution à
vous trouver celle qui vous correspond
le mieux
- vous est-ce que vous avez déjà eu
accès à des services comme du vpn est ce
que tout de suite vous regardez cette
vidéo en utilisant un service de vpn est
ce que pour vous c'est intéressant est
ce que vous voyez vraiment le bénéfice
est ce que vous y avez déjà pensé vous
l'avez jamais fait est-ce que vous ne
connaissiez pas du tout la solution vpn
et est ce que ça vous paraît intéressant
et pertinent marque et matous sans
commentaire parce que c'est intéressant
on va se rendre compte
où est-ce que vous situer par rapport à
ça si elle se rend compte par rapport à
vous tous est ce que vous êtes plutôt
informer là dessus et si vous êtes
plutôt sensibiliser ou alors globalement
pas trop je vous invite comme d'hab
bien sûr un blessé des jo les poudres
merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo des toujours plus nombreux
toujours plus nombreux sur la chaîne
n'hésitez pas à me laisser des jolies
pousse à vous abonner et qui a marqué
toutes vos questions suggestions
interrogations directement en bas en
commentaire merci à vous je vous dis à
très bientôt
et d'ici là soyez sages dix ans
[Musique]